okay so today we're starting a different
different focus for utilitarian looking
at John Stuart Mill and Mel liz is in
the same school as Bethany is a
utilitarian so we say Rogers Payne's
these are the ultimate goods and evils
and what leads to pleasure our measured
pleasure in paying this thing called
utility utility is the propensity to
lead to pleasure overall negative
utility would be that the tendency to
lead to pain which reduce pleasure so if
I give a really bad lecture that lecture
may have negative utility where is
everybody
you would rather be somewhere else at
the time I don't even enjoy it
nobody's getting any pleasure out if
they would have negative utility I give
a really stimulating lecture you're
probably not experiencing the greatest
pleasure in your life but you know enjoy
it you say yeah I got out of that I
enjoy the interaction with the students
it's it's a better experience overall
you could balance these things out you
know we use the example before let's say
we single out one person like mr.
Schwartz we say we're gonna we're all a
bunch of status we're going to pick on
him and make his life miserable because
we all enjoy that he's really going to
hate that that's going to be a lot of
displeasure for him right but the rest
of us may be our pleasure on ways that
that would actually have positive
utility for somebody like benefit it
sounds kind of bad doesn't that you
could countenance doing bad acts because
they bring about positive utility but
that's what utilitarianism says and
that's one of the objections that people
made to utilitarianism they said well
you know this is this could be easier to
say enslave one 1/4 of the population
because they really wouldn't like it but
the other three quarters they would
probably really enjoy it or what if we
could
we could say kill walk half of the
population in very shameless with
painless ways then the rescue courier
could enjoy all these great things that
we've got you know if we have
overcrowding why don't we just you know
do what they did it in some of these
sci-fi movies and have places where
people can go and die in a very nice
peaceful manner and then there they're
not experiencing any any pain after that
right as a matter of fact they're dying
it's actually full of pleasure then
everybody else can have a good time well
you know if that's real tool theory
doesn't leads then we might not want to
take those theory you might see
something wrong
the other big objection that gets made
to utilitarianism as moral theory is one
that Aristotle product back in
Nicomachean ethics book one you remember
he talked about different kinds of
happiness different ideas of happiness
he said well can't be happiness
you guys remember why wealth can't be
happiness what's wrong with making
wealth ultimate goal of your life yeah
very good that wealth is only a means to
other ends that we do in fact desire
more which could be pleasure maybe I
just want to be rich so I can have a big
yacht and a lot of people on the yacht
to two parties drink all day and watch
TV at night or do all sorts of other
things at night maybe that's maybe
that's the good life Aristotle talked
about this right he said what's your on
with the life that's just about pursuing
fire remember that is the life lot I
believe in our time and and back in
Aristotle's time so the many do this
what's wrong with that if there isn't
anything wrong with it then utilitarians
ohms the way to go because it's at least
fair and how things about pleasures
right your pleasure matters as much as
mine I should have deprived you of your
pleasures to make myself a book or
plusclient
what's wrong with with our mana changes
what's wrong with pleasure
Aristotle thinks blender is good what's
wrong with just pursuing pleasure what's
wrong with making that the century
thing become a snake to your pleasures
like you just trying to satisfy those
pleasures that's very good
he and he didn't actually go quite so
far with that but that is sort of long
lines that Aristotle's thinking he used
the word slavish and that you draw out
from that which is something to be
commended some of the implications of
that yeah you become a slave to your
pleasures get away it's a less human
life to just pursue pleasure is a less
human life than the life on for
Aristotle virtuous activity or seeking
knowledge or you can think about this
and a lot of the values that you guys
have expressed that are important to you
you know living a family life is not all
about butter because you're gonna go
home with Thanksgiving is it is it just
be one big sheer joy fest the entire
time they got probably that if it is and
invite me I hope your family that sounds
pretty nice but most families aren't
like that right but family is important
and if you are just pursuing pleasure
you're going to miss out on some things
career is important for you next to it
you guys said that defining a good good
career that actually makes you happy
because you find fulfillment so if
that's the case then maybe there's
something wrong utilitarian
because it is a type of hedonism so mill
you notice part of what he's doing in
this is he's trying to address these
concerns he's saying that you know
here's a bedroom set and I think Bentham
is right is really saying and here's
what other people say and here's the bad
things they say about us
can we actually address them and the way
that he thinks that you can address them
is by making a distinction between
quantitative utilitarianism and
qualitative utilitarianism so the
difference between quantity and quality
what it was a quantity okay yeah
quantity is how much you know this this
holds like two cups of coffee
that's a cuts of quantity right this
book has 600 pages exactly 600 pages
that's kind of rare right this family
has a given amount of ink this chalk can
write on so many chalkboards and produce
so many letters I've no idea how much I
weigh a certain amount these are all
quantities quality is something
different there are you talking about
levels and we can talk about
quantitative differences right this this
piece of chalk is not as much as the
pieces of chalk contain in here another
book I wanted to compare this to but you
know think about most books or not 600
pages this book is longer does that mean
that this book is therefore a better
better and worse
those are qualitative distinctions what
might make this book better at least for
me well because you don't notice it's
not that very good shape right
can read a lot starting to break down
I'm gonna have to put tape on it just to
make it look a little ugly some of the
books that I've read a lot so they have
like spines anymore and you can't see
what the book is I just have to know
what it is on my shelf because I grind
them speech well one thing that makes
this book good is if you want to study
the utilitarians this has both and mill
that that's a qualitative distinction
but could also be quantitated this is to
utilitarians as opposed to just one so
if you went out you wanna bet those
introduction you wouldn't have as much
as as in this book right that's
qualitative we can also talk about it as
being La Follette ated in other ways
because John Stuart Mill a better author
than Jeremy Bentham let me ask you when
you read Bentham how does he read if you
had to like summarize his style in one
sentence I don't I don't get any
enjoyment out of reading them I only get
him dragging out his ideas but you got
to actually wade through the bathroom to
get to those ideas that's because he's
not a good style
what's his style like one two three four
five here's a distinction here's another
distinction here's another distinction
here's another distinction he's actually
pretty boring to read isn't he John
Stuart Mill I hope when you read them
you found him a bit more engaging did
you a little easier to read or
interesting that that's not a
quantitative distinction that's a
qualitative distinction so we can say
that that as a stylist Mill has a higher
quality than Bentham
we could do that for all sorts of things
in this this class all sorts of things
outside of this class you can don't
think about athletics for example every
athlete has one set of numbers attached
I don't mean the ones on their jerseys
right
every athlete if you go online you can
find out
their stats yeah and these stats are
kind of revealing right you can compare
them against each other they're very
sophisticated often quantitative ways of
thinking about things that come up with
all sorts of new ways of measuring stats
over the last 20 years it used to be
that if you had a football card that
would like you know three or four things
that was in it even though the person
was born now you can actually see all
these things does that actually tell you
how good a player the person is what a
sports people talk about sports channels
they talk about qualitative things can
you measure when it comes to others
become football so let's make a
difference of norms well it is
basketball right what makes a good
player I mean like how good a target as
a person as a guard that's more
difficult to measure than how many
baskets
oh yeah yeah you're I guess that's a
position yeah
how well does somebody keep other people
from get into the baskets or how funny
how many times do they pressure somebody
into shooting ahead of time or break up
a play that would be really difficult to
measure because you would have to know
so many faculty but really good sports
casters they know about this was right
there good judges but what's higher and
lower what about music what do we do to
entrust for telling us what's good music
and with bad news do we maybe maybe now
we in the age of the end or we don't
have to just put in things we like and
that it turns out alright but what if
you like really schlocky stuff together
what is banjo area
or shellacking stop right what about
food how do you talk as a colony or even
talk about this right up the road how do
you know that going there is any better
than doing across the street to
McDonald's it cost you more to go to the
colony right that's quantitative people
are fancier there you go to Escoffier
and fancy dress and they'll come out
whether you actually pull covers off the
thing they don't do that even if you ask
does that actually make it any better is
the food any better than up there how
many of you think of it as probably all
of you right what makes it better it's
not just one of these yeah yeah food in
Southport better quality ingredients how
it's prepped is incredibly important
does McDonald's spend a lot of time
attention on what we call plating you
know when you get here when I look at
Don's I get a quarter pounder and I'm
happy if the quarter pounder is in the
Styrofoam container for the paper
container now and the patty is not
actually off-center because somebody was
so fast that they were chewing
everything together then
because that's about as good as a
quarter-pounder gets as far as quality
order converse pretty well now a really
nice meal they actually pay attention to
where they put stuff on the plate it's
kind of strange doesn't change the taste
does it if you know we've all been under
fancy restaurants at one time or another
right you seem like a drizzle sauce you
know instead of just putting it like
here there show us a nice you know a
plastic container next to your things
you can dip whatever it is it here
you're getting to it put it on the plate
why do they do that
yeah yep to make it look better
and again okay wow that's that's a
that's a good observation it doesn't
change the taste right as a matter of
fact it's a pretty inefficient way of
doing sauce if the sauce is supposed to
go on food when I put the sauce right
these yeah the presentation and then we
actually enjoyed that sort of stuff and
cooks had to learn that somebody
actually came up with this there's like
a whole history called kal gastronomy
that's the history of food and this is
all about higher and lower pleasures so
middle is pointing out to us that there
are some pleasures that we can say are
more intense more satisfying and there
are other pleasures that are less
intense less satisfying and what's the
measure for that well which ones do we
actually prefer when we're given the
option if we actually know both of the
pleasures then well if you put the core
powder right here and then what what's
something you guys like to that you
might say get up at the colony sort of
fancy meals
anything we were doing imaginary stuff
so it can be of lavish as you like you
know could be lobster stuffed with
lobster you know it lobster sauce or
something like that anything just
anybody give a suggestion that's
something science for Connors [ __ ] a
steak
what makes a good steak what would you
like to have with your steak or a strip
what does it Peter Luger sauce no what
is it
okay so quarter pounder with cheese look
at stake to you like okay new you a nice
New York Strip that's actually my
favorite and Peter Luger slaws both
sides would you like something fancy
fancy-shmancy
or garlic mashed potatoes everybody like
those are so there's there's our side of
that maybe asparagus but you're not
going to get a McDonald's either now
let's add to it the rest of them so
McDonald's you're going to eat it in the
McDonald's restaurant you sit down in a
plastic booth they're actually making
McDonald's upscale trying to make them
look like Starbucks that's a new thing
but I don't think it's actually hit all
over the place yet so you're going to
see the plastic booth and here a lot of
kids running around you know play and
play which maybe you enjoy if you like
listening to kids yelling at each other
I actually do enjoy it because my kids
live somewhere else
and so for me it reminds me of home but
probably most of you aren't into that
right now the fancy restaurant you'll
sit down at a nice McDonald's doesn't
put table do they does it matter if you
put in the tablecloth does that change
your dining experience do care
some of us some of us don't and some of
us do that on the restaurant McDonald's
they just give the damn money together
nice restaurants right yeah it would
expect it in a nice restaurant
McDonald's are happy if they've wiped it
right and that what they wiped it with
was actually clean isn't that like the
fifth table they wiped hope nobody from
McDonald's watching this look at an
angry call but that's you know that's
the experience that we're used to right
and we can actually say that one is
better and what is worse at that steak
in the fancy restaurant is in fact a
more enjoyable experience and John
Stuart Mill okay well how do you find
that out well you have to experience
both of those this can't just be some
upper crust silver spoon person who only
experiences the finer things in life and
actually know them to be the finer
things in life if you have a thoroughly
experienced both pleasures that you're
comparing you can't tell whether they're
actually better or worse so if you
haven't experienced them you might ask
somebody who he has know would call that
person an ideal judge as a matter of
fact millets and go out and experience a
lot of pleasures so you can in fact
compare them so you can tell whether
you're doing the lower pleasure
something that's a less value or a
higher pleasure
what about pains we can do the same
thing with this some pains are less
disruptive of our life they they don't
bother us as much how can you tell which
are worse pains
qualitatively
quantitatively qualitatively and which
are not so bad you ask somebody who's
actually experienced building let's
think about just plain old physical
right how many of you have tattoos quite
a few hundred hurts to get a tattoo this
one doesn't hurt maybe you have a very
high pain threshold most people say it
hurts not not terrible not how did what
do they compare to yeah yeah some are
getting pretty painful too bad that when
I grew in the era before we had to do
some screens when I go out every spring
and get myself terribly burned leopards
apply either worse physical things than
that how many have ever been badly
burned burns really not like summer but
actually the bernburg that really hurts
doesn't that hurt worse than being
tattooed you think barb cat-scratch it's
different kind of hurt
that we actually being hurt over a lot
of your body that's really me
pickles burn victims that you see
sometimes that's they say that that's
one of the worst physical pains
experienced they do say so if you're
contesting whether it's for the worst
getting really burned this is what this
is what people actually say no that's
saying if you want to know about
pleasures and pains you actually are
going to experience them and then find
out let's think now about psychological
pleasures and pains what are some easy
to put up with pains or no answers
psychological thing bored anybody ever
died of boredom with sometimes a dying
nobody actually does and if you had
thick dying of boredom being being very
very bored and like let's say what would
be another particularly family Oh being
made fun let's say you have any of you
ever seen those those Comedy Central
roasts well they're pretty vicious
aren't they
can you imagine people saying that sort
of stuff about you if you were on there
you know it's not Flavor Flav or who
else do we see recently Chevy Chase
really disagreeable guy when he was
being rusty we watch those that's why
we're just amazed and I'm I'm kind of
jaded but I'm amazed at just how crude
and crass and hurtful these people can
be and it's just like one thing after
another I couldn't take that I couldn't
have I couldn't sit up there napkin
saying that sermon with a giant audience
all laughing I would definitely say you
know be for ten years or have to go
through one of those things I'd be bored
for 10 years but I interview experience
being bored
I've never experienced being bored for
more than like a day or other
psychological things we can compare
against each other we don't like being
made fun of we don't like being bored
that's what else hurts us well let's
let's not think about something what are
some of the pains that you've
experienced some of you have been burnt
some of you have gotten tattooed
some of you then can't scratch it you
can compare it to a cat scratch right
anybody have a dog bite them like really
quick all them anybody haven't dorm just
nip you i got hurts you've all had
infections one formerly another cotton
gets infected the cat scratches you
don't often gets infected human being by
to guarantee you become in factories or
Mouser the dirtiest things on the planet
bacteria as it turns out worse than
what other pains you know how when
you're a kid there's every one of you
had some sort of lesson that you learn
don't do this anymore
but you may have touched the hot stove
or my two one were don't mess with the
mousetrap because it will snap on your
finger that's going to hurt a lot and
then don't take the car keys and put
them in the electrical socket because
that's not playing car right and I
remember the feeling of that burnt you
know and I remember like a big flash and
falling backwards and that was not
pleasant at all but then I remember
later on getting shocked that was really
dumb but I prefer getting shocked to
know when you're messing with an
extension cord and I actually
accidentally touched the time that was
going into it and I felt a literally no
shock there was an electric shock I said
let me find out it again and sure enough
it was it wasn't that bad and then there
was you know you've all like done this
the does an idle battery still work you
touch it to your time and sure enough it
works and it doesn't feel good but it's
not like horrifyingly bad right that
maybe just quantitative right but maybe
there's some quality things getting
shocked worse than being more how many
of you been forward all of you right at
one time how many the child okay those
are going to been shocked
you got any one of the other you're
going to be bored or you're going to get
an electric shock a really good you
rather be bored you'd rather take the
shot why would you rather before because
it
my anchor yeah why would you rather get
the shaft I only sleep like two hours a
day so multiples for the day and know
what it's like to be bored
no one's there to talk to enough that
comes up so quick shackle doer
well in that case I reckon being bored
as something that you're sort of taking
as a gift right so Nate what we'd have
to do in a case like this and doesn't
talk about this no leader says why you
need judges that have experienced both
maybe we'd have to look at which judges
and say their experience is closer to
the norm but he doesn't go into that but
the general idea is that we can in fact
not only measure pleasures and pains
against each other by quantity but by
quality now let's think about
that's a good question so is the scale
as objective as possible or throughout
the alright there's a scale just for an
individual or as an objective as
possible done through an entire
community nil is very fuzzy about that
it's great at sketching out a project
when it comes to the actually saying how
this would be done it's very easy to do
it for individuals who just consult
their through different preferences
right providing they've experienced
sufficient types of pleasures and pains
that words when it comes to a community
then you wind up with these sort of
disagreements and he doesn't tell you
how to decide between those he just says
well you have to consult the best judges
well it would be the better judge in
this case would it be him or her we
don't have a decision procedure for that
mill doesn't address that satisfied
everyone
for the majority
well that would be a way of deciding it
if you say we're going to take the
majority so let's do that right now
who who agrees that give them the chance
to get shocked pretty bad shot or to be
bored you would rather be shot who said
raise your hands and you everyone has to
vote so we'll get shocked are you the
only person you'd rather get shocked -
it's okay if you do you know we were
just consulting preferences here a
really nasty one you know like like when
I stuck the kid to the valve
nothing insulating nothing in between
years and then 110 current ah okay how
the rest of you would prefer to be bored
rather than to be so we would have
decided it by an appeal to majority
right but that's a way of deciding no
doesn't actually go as far as saying do
that he just says well you consult the
best judges on it and he does tell us
what the judges would be like they have
experienced both the pleasures of a
question or both the pains in question
thoroughly so they know them inside and
out they just have a momentary exposure
to it I suppose you know who would be
the best judge to ask in this sort of
case
I bet an electrician you know why
because they get shocked in an awful lot
don't they but at least look that when
they're starting hopefully the
keep my shot they get better at their
job they don't shock quite so much maybe
they would be the ideal judge in this
sort of case when it comes to pain
physical pain you would probably want to
consult people who actually feel that
kind of a good experience that's right
you know I haven't been tattooed you I
can tell you what it's like to be brand
that is paint that's where you actually
burn something into design into here
you're flush I wouldn't do that again
I also had you know really good reason
because it really hurt and I only did it
for like five seconds it was kind of one
really thing with so many way hadn't
kept in touch with he did it for like
ten seconds he was tougher than I was
that hurt him off a lot then you know I
remember I was in karate class after
that and I had lucky it was a band-aid
on and somebody grabbed my whoa that was
belonging and I don't think I would want
to trade that for most of the pains that
I've experienced but there are
somethings like logical things then I
might say I would rather feel that again
somebody like pushing right into the
ground that's that's brand-new I'd
rather feel that they go through that
kind of psychological pain what are some
of the pains that you dread feeling you
have but you think are going to be
really bad
sure could be physical pain yeah that is
very traumatic is the death of somebody
close to you right yeah yeah
that's really tough I've gone through a
lot myself my mom my dad best friend
girlfriend at one time all my
grandparents the penile monolith after a
while you get to know that that sort of
feeling it actually helps you to
empathize with other people
and I look at some of my friends like
Iowa I'm in front of sixty years old
their parents are in their 90's
she has never experienced a death of
something close to her in her life I
think Wow one of her parents dies that
is just going to be devastating
because I know what it feels I know
those of you that have experienced
deaths you know it feels right it's hard
it hurts a lot you know it doesn't seem
an meeting you miss the person for years
sometimes afterwards but that's very
very tough which would you rather have
branding or somebody close to you died
yeah you can say there's a qualitative
difference some pains are worse or more
intense than others
what if what are other things in dread
to happen to you
yeah I'm not successful that is a big
one
let's let's unpack Oh what what does it
mean to not be successful in this
society yeah to have the things that you
felt like you could achieve drawn up
short that hurts and you guys right now
are at a point in time where you have a
lot of control you're in college that's
a great thing
getting college degree all the learning
that goes with it that's arming you for
your life you can look around you can
see a lot of failed wives a lot of
people do live up to their potential how
are they looked at in our society are
they treated
not by everybody a lot of people I'm
proud of how do we treat them in this
society and most other societies do this
do ya there Sean and look down when you
see somebody whose retirement age
there's a lot more that's happening now
you see somebody's retirement age and
you would think ought to be doing
themselves and they probably worked a
regular job through the portion of the
life and the serving your food at
McDonald's something's going on in that
person's life that is not people are not
working at six years old behind the
counter at McDonald's because they said
I want to work at McDonald's this is
going to be the greatest thing for me if
they do that their managers right there
consultants if their lives if something
happened to them things got so screwed
up that now they have to take what they
feel to be the job that's beneath them
many people do take jobs that they feel
they're beneath them that's not pleasant
this that's painful they often inflict
as much pain on themselves as other
people do and other people do look down
on them don't they how do people treat
the greeters at Walmart very odd
the readers are there and they're
required like you know sipping smile and
say hi to everybody that's tough to do
especially when how do people actually
treat them I'm not saying you but how do
you see could get there yeah so imagine
eight hours a day being required to
follow a script and being treated as if
you're in the lanes can you get the hell
out of my way I just want to current
people say things that's hurtful and
that over over time that cuts down on
somebody's we call self-esteem your
self-image
or their self-respect and that's
something that a lot of people would
dread experience some people lose their
jobs and they kill themselves because
they can't imagine doing something on
the horse nation it's easier for
somebody like me because my family is
mostly lower middle class that he
managed to quaters or plotted way up
into the middle class and then a lot of
you are the same - right but if you are
coming from an environment where you're
expecting to be a high performer all the
time and you can't measure up you feel
great psychological distress and people
often say that's a worse pain what else
is particularly what are you know the
other outcomes for your life
yeah cancer oh yeah very painful
oftentimes the painkiller drugs can't
control pain setting that is one reason
why people propose and often do use
euthanasia right they say the pain is
going to be too terrible if you're
utilitarian you might say that would be
a good thing is that you know physically
even mentally - very debilitating
diseases Alzheimer's is particularly bad
psychologically I remember my
grandfather going through it maybe some
of you have these experiences too and
there's there's a time before the
Alzheimer gets too bad and they don't
know what's going on at all there's a
time between the first loss of memory
and first sort of not having it together
and up to the you know real dementia
stage where they actually know what's
going on they realize that they have
Alzheimer's and they are not who they
are and you can see the person kind of
smoking away and becoming more
frustrated and as it goes on they have
less and less conception of what is
actually wrong but they know something's
wrong that's pretty bad isn't it how do
you want them I think not you want that
for you
you're close to her lock as a matter of
fact if you're pretty pretty sympathetic
if you have a lot of charity towards
your fellow Dean's you probably wouldn't
want anybody you can recognize that is
fairly objective yeah so we can compare
these things to each other we can say
some pains are so bad that no other
pains can really compare to them now
what could be the options for this
remember we talked with utilitarianism
can the trade plenty off against paints
can we say punish mr. Schwartz
the terrible condition and the rest of
us derive pleasure from it that could be
okay from a quantitative point of view
all right what did we say that we're not
what were we going to do to you make fun
right the psychological distress that
comes with that might be so bad we're
not bullying bullying is a big topic so
we're going to bully you so mercilessly
I remember this happening because I was
in school I remember a kid actually on
the baseball diamond being bullied so
bad that he actually picked up a bat and
just started swinging and luckily he was
he sort of telegraphed what he was going
to do because otherwise he would've
probably killed somebody and the reason
he did it was because everybody was
screwing with and not just like screwing
with him a little bit just constantly
screwing and finally one day
it was too much and he snapped and then
everybody knew after that kid don't
don't mess with him anymore
what was going on there from a
qualitatively to latarian perspective he
had inflicted on him something that was
very high level of pain not just
qualitatively not just time after time
after time qualitatively he'd been made
to feel like he was nothing that's
terrible and you know when any of you
say well I'll accept the pleasures I
think about the great pleasures of you
I'll accept these pleasures but I'll
have to put up with this kind of pain
does that make any sense to do that
would it make sense to say well we're
going to do that to pick on somebody
else mr. Singh now right we're going to
do that to mr. Singh we're going to how
do you mercilessly because we all get a
kick out we all get a little charge out
of it so we all have quantitatively a
greater amount of pleasure than he has
pain but qualitatively his pain is worse
this allows us to talk about things like
the dignity of human beings there are
some things that are against the dignity
of a human being mercilessly making fun
of someone treats them as less than a
human right
what are other things that could be like
that that we could rule out we could say
that utilitarian can't go for this let's
think about this here's an interesting
question of things for me it's Lillet
Aryan perspective valuating thinks in
terms of pleasures and pains is it worse
to kill somebody or to rape somebody
again just in terms of pleasures and
pains if you kill somebody what happens
they feel they don't they're not happy
that you're killing them right yeah I
think I think arguably it would be do
you disagree what first of all it
depends how one's die sure so let's
let's let's set some parameters but you
go up somebody you shoot it with that
that's what
right that's what you think but now
we're looking at how utilitarian comes
right remember just pains and pleasures
so put aside with you is a personal
thing and if we only consider this in
terms of pains and pleasures they don't
want to experience any more pain yeah
rape victims experience a lot of pain
not just at the moment of rape but
throughout right we're not debating that
we're talking we're looking at it from a
utilitarian perspective sure but let's
do this now let's actually go through
the exercise and thinking about it from
utilitarian perspective and seeing why
great would be worse so one is one is
over very quickly the other one goes on
for a long time so that's that's
quantity is there anything qualitative
sure and then we can say kill somebody
you're going to affect all their loved
ones but if you rape somebody but if you
kill someone won't there be more green
brought about
someone who is just not necessarily in
order to do that would be sort of an
empirical thing that you'd have to go
and look at people who've actually been
killed go and see how much their
families are affected
I don't want some cultures to actually
much work than who've been family to
have somebody killed it's absolutely
great that somebody killed so I wouldn't
take it as a given people are affected
more by yeah in this case getting that
person will be okay take let's say years
but on rain will be a lifetime yeah now
all of this is again quantity number of
people affected time doesn't talk about
those in terms of you know intensity
time duration number of people those are
all things that fit into let's think
about in terms of qualitative things
yeah person is killed there there could
be ways that are very very humiliating
ways to be killed and oftentimes when
people are made examples of that's done
with them why is rape so bad
what is what is going on in our in a
rape psychological pain yeah the person
who is being raped is being treated as
if they're not a person at all
I mean there's people who make these
claims about rape is all about power and
about sex or just all angry not about
science that's debatable
right it could be about any of those
things but in any case whether you're
treating somebody as less than human
because of power or because inability to
control sexual urges the rapist is
treating a person as less than a person
not just as a little less than person
but as nothing this is part of what rape
victims talk about as the psychological
harm that comes is why it's a lot of
time for the government right and some
people never do because for you know
whatever five minutes five hours five
weeks they had been treated as if they
don't matter at all and somebody else
becomes the center of the world because
they're able to put something torture
could be along those lines to in some
ways being tortured extensively could be
worse than dying right you can add other
things to that some people if they're
involved in political movements or
there's a military personnel they would
prefer to die than to be captured
tortured and then forced to give up
information because that would be a
great psychological harm to them and you
know the means of torture that have been
developed ever since you know really the
last century
they can turn person inside out it's not
just you know reasons the stuff that was
done during World War two
gulags slowly pretty horrific can read
it up and you know we can think of that
again in terms of worse pains more
horrifying experiences that you would
want to set things up so people don't
have to experience even if other people
get a lot of pleasure torturers
generally enjoyed during their work why
their torturers
you can actually torture somebody to get
some useful information on them from a
qualitative utilitarian perspective
that's perfectly fine from a qualitative
utilitarian perspective there might be
some things that you simply want not to
do or ought not to inflict on other
people Mike because know also says well
you do to balance out quantity and
quality he doesn't actually tell us how
to do this it's easy to sketch things
out but anytime that somebody is talking
about while we have to look the whole
community and balance out the costs of
the benefits to its people what they're
doing is they're engaging in utilitarian
thinking they're proposing you look at
things as utilitarian we've looked at
down two different ways which this can
be done quantitatively what's the
advantage of doing that it's easy to
figure out right
what would be an example of that are you
guys familiar with this Ford Pinto case
it's kind of a famous case in consumer
things the Ford Pinto used to blow up
when people would run into it from
behind this is a long time this when I
was a kid
hey the Ford Pinto was designed poorly
so that the gas tank was in such a place
that if you rear-ended it at a certain
speed it would blow up like a fireball
and Ford knew about this and they did a
cost-benefit analysis and they figured
well ultra cost us for each case where
somebody dies to pay out to the families
this is what you know the life is worth
how much would it cost us to recall the
Pinto well it would cost us a lot more
to recall the Pinto than to pay out this
money so we're going to go with leave
the Pinto is out there and it would have
been okay not okay orally but it would
have been okay for the for corporation
if people haven't started investigating
and they started investigating because
it were awful lot of pintles going on
and they started investigating this and
they found out that the Ford corporation
had actually made this decision where
they said call them or don't recall them
and pay out this amount of money to the
families or recall them and pay out this
amount of money let's go with this they
did quantum utilitarian thinking
qualitative perspective that would have
probably have been a bad decision
because again what are you doing you're
treating human beings
they are justice money certain batches
of money would any of you like that
to be treated like that or find out that
your family had been treated like how
would you feel if you found out there
was a dollar value set on ooh you guys
are too young to have kids how would you
feel if there was dollar value so
and that was okay for your mom to get
killed because this amount will be paid
out to you that'll that'll you know
compensate for your pain and suffering
how would you feel if you found out that
Sony was thinking
sure olivine would influence I'm sure
you have feelings great now just
watching imagine where your feelings
show me that you like your mom this is
some sort of scenario where you really
don't like your mom you might say well
not really that much pain and suffering
I'll take the money anyway assuming that
you all do actually longue carabine
how would you feel somebody else has put
a dollar value on your head feel angry
what's up above anger what's above anger
that's a good point
rage or what else do some graph yeah
I mean there this actually goes to sign
one of the ways in which type of thing
with the ideal judge one of the ways in
which you can tell whether a given pain
or discomfort or something
would really be bad is if you think to
yourself about somebody suffering it and
you have this this reaction Wow somebody
who does that something want to be done
to them do you have that emotional
reaction that's probably a sign provided
your emotions are you know in balance
track that that's a particularly bad
qualitatively bad pain to inflict eyes
if you look at somebody who's been
starved to death which happens to
something later
rare society you feel very upset about
that you feel disgusted you feel angry
you feel certainly you know this
shouldn't have happened that's the right
emotional reaction him that's a sign
that that's a particularly big crook if
it's a pain that you would trade off
other games actually this could be
compensated by some money right I mean
you could pay me to get branded again
don't do that
that's be quite a bit of money when you
go to the bar and somebody says buy a
drink if you get Brandon I wouldn't do
that because that pleasure isn't you
know anywhere near as good as pain but
you can pay me $10,000 and I do it
because $10,000 can buy me a lot of
pleasures that would compensate I think
when we're dealing with lower pleasures
and pains it's very easy to measure them
against each other I think the more
intense they get harder it becomes to
measure so a lot of concepts being
thrown at you so higher in little
pleasures who can judge between them
those who have experienced both of them
fully we'll talk more about this again
next class after after Thanksgiving
break and then we're actually going to
look at some some scenarios and try to
figure out how a utilitarian would deal
with this with a quantitative
utilitarian and quantity so have a good
Thanksgiving right